for these firefighters in western Canada
this is a daunting and potentially
deadly situation raging wildfires fanned
by strong winds with more than 100
burning across Alberta the province's
top official has declared a state of
emergency this is not a step that we
took lately but it's one that will allow
the quickest and most effective response
visiting one of the worst affected areas
she says the situation is unprecedented
and warned it was far from over it could
last a long time weeks if if not months
the Fire officer was just telling me
that they had similar because of the the
PV soil they had a similar fire that
took over a year to extinguish
after a week of record heat across
western Canada officials say
persistently dry weather is to blame for
the fires the temperature and the wind
combined with the lack of precipitation
this year really created this mix that
created the extreme virus that we
entered a fire ban a week before this
fire broke out in the county
the arrival of more favorable weather
conditions in the South has allowed
firefighters to reach previously
inaccessible areas but conditions remain
difficult in the north and in
neighboring British Columbia where
authorities worn hot and dry conditions
are due to return in the coming days and
could further fuel the Flames that's
prompted more orders to evacuate people
from their homes and the fear there
could be more wildfires to come Cara leg
Al Jazeera